il ya donc trois ans le mouvement des
gels et jaune faisait trembler
l'exécutif les revendications honte elle
était entendue on en débat tout de suite
avec nos invités gilles casanova expert
en stratégie et communication et qui
arrive rougeyron à président du cercle
aristote
bonsoir messieurs merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur arte france d'abord
est ce qu'on peut parler d'un retour des
gilet jaune gilles casanova
oui et non les gilet jaune n'ont jamais
disparu les problèmes qui sont au coeur
de leur apparition n'ont pas disparu le
rejet de la politique qui
amène toute une série de gens à se
sentir à la fois rejeté à la fois placé
dans une situation sociale difficile
alors qu'il travaille alors qu'ils vont
un métier qui devrait l'être de vivre
correctement cela ça n'a pas changé la
crise sanitaire a même accru le
phénomène ce qui a changé c'est
l'innocence c'est à dire que au départ
des gens se sont regroupés sur des ronds
points pour se parler des problèmes
qu'ils avaient en commun ils ont
découvert un peu la politique
aujourd'hui ils ont très bien compris de
quoi tout cela parle mais ils ont aussi
compris qu'on ne pas les écouter
pierre rivard rougeyron c'est vrai que
les jets les jaunes et promettent
maintenant de manifester jusqu'à cette
échéance très importante en france
élection présidentielle est-ce qu'il
faut faut imaginer que tous les samedis
qui se profile risque de d'être
aujourd'hui finalement
alors cela dépend de la masse qui
arrivera à être mobilisés le il n'est
pas dit et on peut le regretter on peut
l'accepter que les gilet jaune et
disons le même magnétisme sociale je
vous rappelle les mouvements sociaux de
contestation comme les bonnets rouges en
bretagne autres ne sont pas arrivés à
renaître de leurs cendres
il n'est pas impossible ce pour des
raisons sociologiques et politiques et
entre autres le fait qu'une partie du
mouvement ait été digéré digéré par la
répression policière digéré par là
l'infiltration de forces politiques et
syndicales qui ont écoeuré une partie
non négligeable des militants et digérer
on trouve par la société du spectacle
qui a mis en scène une partie des
anciens leaders des gilets jaunes il
n'est pas dit que
qu'ils puissent avoir la même force de
mobilisation d'accord avec cette année
j'ai une casanova les gilets jaunes ont
été attaqués par le haut et par le bas
par le bas avec l'initiative très
intelligente du gouvernement qui a
consisté à dégager les ronds points
parce que c'était cela la base du
mouvement c'était là que se forge est
collectivement la force de ce mouvement
et donc le fait d'avoir fait place nette
sur ces ronds-points à ramener les gens
devant leur poste de télévision
sanaa dont plus du tout le même sens et
par le haut puisque ce mouvement a
commis ce que on peut considérer que
d'une erreur
pour ne pas tomber dans le narcissisme
du jeu politique et tourner pas être
récupéré et la considérait qu'ils ne
devaient avoir aucune structuration
aucune organisation aucun porte parole
mais l'anthropologie nous apprend que
tout groupe humain qui se réunit concis
constitue aussitôt enfoncé des
hiérarchies leadership et qu'à un moment
donné il ne peut pas se poursuivre s'ils
ne réalisent pas cela les mouvements
estudiantins des années 70 par exemple
qui avait une grande défiance vis-à-vis
des forces politiques se sont auto
organisés de manière verticale avec des
collectifs nationaux et bien aujourd'hui
on peut constater que pendant les trente
ans qui ont suivi les leaders de la
gauche ils ont été produits par ces gens
qui étaient défiant ville artix et qui
vous êtes d'accord avec tes rivaux
rougeyron lorsqu'il dit qu'à une base
des gilet jaune finalement qui a été
happé par le système donc par le bas
comme je vous disais en liquidant les
ronds-points par le haut parce qu'ils
n'ont pas voulu avoir une structuration
le système médiatique a piqué un certain
nombre d'entre eux pour en faire des
divas de médias et à partir de ce moment
là il ne rendait plus compte à personne
et n'ont jamais rendu compte y a pas de
structuration donc ils ont couru deux
chaînes d'information en chaîne
d'informations en essayant de dire ce
qu'il leur semblait bien à eux
personnellement mais naturellement toute
une série de gens ne se sentaient pas
représenté d'autant qu'un certain nombre
de ces divas d' médias inventé par le
système médiatique et les chaînes
d'information
ont pris position pour une organisation
politique pour une organisation
syndicale et donc ont donné le sentiment
que finalement le mouvement se faisait
manger par le jeu politique et
médiatique gérons pourtant il ya un
contexte quand même très favorable à une
relance du mouvement bon il était quand
même nombreux aujourd'hui à paris en
région ce contexte bien c'est toujours
ce prix
à la pompe qui augmente un plus que
j'avais c'est ce qui a d'ailleurs initié
le mouvement au départ il ya aussi
toujours ce pouvoir d'achat qui est en
baisse des restrictions sanitaires aussi
se passe sanitaire qui est très contesté
donc ça c'est un point convergence aussi
avec ceux qui se mobilisent kyi qui
conteste d'ailleurs
la vaccination aussi
tout a empiré tout empiré depuis le
début du mouvement des gels et jaune bon
là on va être sur des critères encore
bien pire que le critère du disons du
prix à la pompe on va être sûr de
l'inflation sur des matières des denrées
alimentaires on va être sur des
problèmes sur le l'énergie sur le
chauffage donc tout tout est réuni pour
que ce soit une course une une
contestation d'ampleur
néanmoins il ya une méfiance qu'il faut
avoir c'est de ce qu'on appelle dans le
temps le le spontanéisme révolutionnaire
c'est à dire tout et tout est prêt à
péter donc ça va péter malheureusement
une large partie des gens qui ont déjà
participé à ces mouvements n'y
reviendront pas
le l'aspect anarchique des des
manifestations d'aujourd'hui ne fait que
le confirmer et surtout
les gens ont peur peur de la
généralisation de la répression peur du
climat de folie qui a pris dans en
occident depuis deux ans sur les
questions sanitaires et sur le fait
qu'on a pris sur les questions de santé
une partie de la population en otage
pour les aides pour les dresser contre
les éventuels manifestants
donc le la le pouvoir à des cartes de
répression qu'il n'avait pas au moment
de la crise des gilets jaunes et une
fois j'ai les casanova ce qui se passe
en guadeloupe par exemple où la
l'exécuter semble dépassée il ya eu un
conseil interministériel en fin
d'après-midi il ya des renforts qui vont
être envoyés là bas pour essayer
justement d'éviter de nouvelles
violences sur place sans cause c'est le
pass and i ter l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants puis on voit ce qui
se passe aussi ailleurs en europe et au
pays basque et hier avec des forces de
l'ordre complètement dépassés qui ont
tiré même sur des coups de sommation et
même sur des manifestants donc ça c'est
un contexte aussi qui qui peut laisser
penser que les gilets jaunes ont un
boulevard aussi d'ici l'élection
présidentielle
il y à mille raisons que le pays explose
beaucoup plus qu'en mai 1968 par exemple
mais ce qui fait l'explosion ce n'est
pas le nombre de raisons pour exploser
ce qui fait l'explosion c'est qu'il y à
un débouché qui lie à une fenêtre par
laquelle on peut voir un avenir meilleur
or la crise sanitaire d'une part
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas au pouvoir un
parti politique mais un groupe très
restreint qui n'a peur de rien 2,2 pour
cent des exprimés aux élections
municipales 3,5 pour cent des inscrits
aux élections régionales avec neuf
ministres présentés pour autant et ça
n'a absolument pas embarrassé ni le
président ni son gouvernement
dont le rôle est un peu diaphane
aujourd'hui et donc ça veut dire qu'ils
n'ont peur de rien précédemment les
partis socialistes ou bolis deux
versions
du dr ump x été rachetés il avait le
besoin de maintenir les élus de leur
parti et de maintenir leurs appareils
donc ils étaient obligés de négocier de
tenir compte de ce qui se passait dans
la société là il y a simplement besoin
d'avoir 21 22% au premier tour et d'être
sûr d'être opposée à quelqu'un qu'on
présentera comme le nouvel hitler ou
hitler en jupon pour que dans un réflexe
de peur on est une légère majorité au
second tour donc on a absolument aucun
souci du débat public ou qu'un pierre
yves rougeyron c'est une analyse comment
quand vous partagez
totalement totalement le emmanuel macron
a compris que le premier mouvement des
gilet jaune lui est en partie favorable
je m'explique
par la violence qu'il a déchaîné il a
coagulé une part de la bourgeoisie
française qui ne rêvait que du ce que
202 projette de prolétaires depuis des
années aucun gouvernement
futile de droite ne lui avait accordé sa
or on revend les yeux et en coupant les
mains emmanuel macron à solidifier son
socle électoral malheureusement et la
violence qui l'utilisent encore contre
le mouvement type hassan et ter ne fait
que renforcer ce socle électoral dont il
a impérativement besoin pour passer le
second tour sachant qu arriver au second
il a quasiment toutes les chances de
l'emporter mais pour conclure rapidement
ce n'est pas sur justement que la
réponse sécuritaire à aa toutes ses
vagues de contestations gilet jaune on
le voit offrir en guadeloupe contre le
passé ni terre c'est pas sûr que ça
calme quand même les esprits
c'est pas le but c'est le but n'est pas
de calmer le but est de dominer et le
but est d'entretenir
disons un climat de haine sociale qui
permet aux pouvoirs de 2,2 de dire à une
partie de la bourgeoisie française et de
la petite bourgeoisie c'est soit vous
renouveler le bail de la macro ni et
nous vous défendront contre les les
affreux prolos les affreux non vaccinés
il ya toujours un bouc émissaire à
trouver soit vous c'est nous soit c'est
avec eux que vous devrez gérer donc vous
n'avez pas le choix vous devez
reconduire le bail des manuels macro ses
lectures aux sicav partager un kavanagh
va très très rapidement
on a mis fin au débat droite gauche or
nous sommes dans un pays qui vit de
discute donc si on a plus droite gauche
on à la lutte des classes et emmanuel
macron pratique ce que tiers avait créé
c'est à dire la lutte des classes la
formule que mars l'ua reprise merci à
vous j'ai casanova expert en stratégie
et communication et merci à vous qui
arrive à rougeyron président à des
cercles arrive cat